Caption: welcome everyone I hope you've been
Caption: enjoying the event
Caption: um and managed to get something tasty to
Caption: eat for lunch now our next speaker is
Caption: Trent Jones his talk is going to be
Caption: about architecture for all Trent from AI
Caption: media has been designing building and
Caption: testing software for over 10 years
Caption: across a wide wide variety of Industries
Caption: he has a passion for devops and
Caption: inclusive software along with a lifelong
Caption: love of sharing and learning over to
Caption: Trent
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you everyone for for joining me
Caption: today so uh this is a little talk I've
Caption: been developing across a number of
Caption: different
Caption: um
Caption: engagements in my previous life I was a
Caption: consultant so I did a lot of
Caption: architecture diagramming and
Caption: um the various likes uh so thank you for
Caption: joining me um first off thank you to all
Caption: the sponsors today wouldn't be possible
Caption: without them all so it's really
Caption: appreciated I know they they Rock up
Caption: year after year so yeah really
Caption: appreciate them
Caption: um so I thought I'd start off with a
Caption: quote architecture represents the
Caption: significant design decisions that shape
Caption: a system where significance is measured
Caption: by the cost of change
Caption: and the really important part here for
Caption: me is that last
Caption: part of the sentence significant is
Caption: measured by the cost of change these
Caption: decisions in your architecture diagrams
Caption: in your architecture
Caption: um you know they have a cost associated
Caption: with them changing them is not as simple
Caption: as just swapping a component now
Caption: generally speaking maybe you've got
Caption: micro services and it is easy but
Caption: generally speaking they're quite complex
Caption: tasks
Caption: um so I really like that quote it's a
Caption: great
Caption: setting
Caption: so on to diagrams whose audience
Caption: audience participation who's done a
Caption: diagram before who's done an
Caption: architecture one
Caption: nice how many of you have done it on a
Caption: whiteboard
Caption: no external whiteboard yeah how many
Caption: have done like more professional used a
Caption: bit of software and had to store it in
Caption: the system where everyone references
Caption: cool so we're all pretty familiar with
Caption: architecture diagram sets
Caption: um so some examples uh
Caption: this one lots of boxes barely any labels
Caption: there's a bunch of arrows in the middle
Caption: there that are so close together you
Caption: can't even see where they're going
Caption: um I'm probably guilty of doing this at
Caption: some point in time there's been some
Caption: complex systems in the past uh
Caption: but overall you don't get a great
Caption: picture of what's going on here there's
Caption: there's lots of lots of pretty colors
Caption: and lots of a few arrows but not much
Caption: else to really tell you what this system
Caption: does or how it behaves
Caption: uh what about this one
Caption: same sort of thing
Caption: um it's a little bit more spread out so
Caption: it's got that going for it
Caption: um a bit better use of colors
Caption: objectively maybe perhaps
Caption: um
Caption: a few more labels again perhaps there's
Caption: there's actually a label on one of the
Caption: arrows there which may or may not be
Caption: useful to you but at the end of the day
Caption: it's still kind of difficult to see
Caption: what's going on with this architecture
Caption: diagram
Caption: um and then lastly I have this pretty
Caption: whiteboard drawing
Caption: um this is probably honestly the best
Caption: out of all of them it's even got some
Caption: users in there down the bottom in green
Caption: lots of the the arrows and the data flow
Caption: is actually labeled
Caption: um
Caption: but yeah they're old at the end of the
Caption: day they're all just boxes that's boring
Caption: what the hell are these compo what are
Caption: these actual components is it like a an
Caption: ec2 box running uh Java spring boot or
Caption: is it a Lambda micro service like what's
Caption: actually going on in this architecture
Caption: who knows
Caption: um so stop it don't do it anymore
Caption: um
Caption: this is a site that I didn't delete when
Caption: I was meant to so let's skip that one uh
Caption: my purging last night clearly missed a
Caption: slide
Caption: um so I wanted to talk through a
Caption: scenario because I thought that was the
Caption: best way to kind of illustrate how we
Caption: might go about designing better
Caption: architecture diagrams so I came up with
Caption: a cannery don't ask me why my brain
Caption: works in weird ways uh so products are
Caption: randomly sampled as they go along the
Caption: conveyor belt they're tested for
Caption: anomalies and we take some action right
Caption: so there's there's something that does
Caption: that randomly random sampling uh there's
Caption: something that detects that random
Caption: sample event and actually makes a change
Caption: in the system we have to do something to
Caption: take that sample from the product and
Caption: then we get results back we get a parcel
Caption: fail from that sample and again we have
Caption: to take action
Caption: um if it fails if it's good then we
Caption: continue doing whatever it is a cannery
Caption: does and we profit hopefully
Caption: uh so
Caption: this is a plausible architecture right
Caption: it's not a good one I'll give you that
Caption: but it's a plausible architecture we
Caption: have a sensor it's sending some sort of
Caption: data to a sampling engine there we have
Caption: a pretty box the box I said don't do
Caption: because boxes are not good if the sample
Caption: fails
Caption: it goes around to a staff member
Caption: don't know what sort of staff member is
Caption: it the the cleaner or is it the manager
Caption: like who are we actually sending that to
Caption: is it the CEO that gets the message
Caption: um and then
Caption: the staff member sends something back to
Caption: the center what are they sending back to
Caption: the sensor
Caption: um there's not a lot of information
Caption: going on here but
Caption: I can almost guarantee that there's
Caption: architecture diagrams like this out in
Caption: the wild
Caption: um
Caption: so all we can oh we can really tell from
Caption: this with any great certainty is that
Caption: when we get sample results back we we do
Caption: something with those sample results
Caption: right we could see those uh those data
Caption: flow labels the sample pass and Sample
Caption: failed that's the only real certainty we
Caption: can get out of this architecture diagram
Caption: um so let's iterate
Caption: so now we have a production line we can
Caption: see what's actually happening here from
Caption: the production line there's there's
Caption: two-way data flow between the random
Caption: sample sensor which has a better name
Caption: now by the way it's not just a sensor
Caption: it's a random sample sensor we've got
Caption: really descriptive
Caption: um labels associated with these things
Caption: uh the random sample sensor we still
Caption: don't know what it's doing it's just
Caption: passing something into a black box
Caption: sampling engine we we still don't know
Caption: what that sampling engine does
Caption: um we can see when it passes we actually
Caption: go and restart the or restart or
Caption: continue the production line we that
Caption: label might need some work
Caption: um and we can see the manager at some
Caption: point presses the start button but we
Caption: don't really know when that is so
Caption: arguably better maybe worse
Caption: um
Caption: hopefully it illustrates a point though
Caption: so now we can see that we've got
Caption: something generating a sample event we
Caption: we know a bit more about what's
Caption: happening in this system from from this
Caption: um there's probably a few other bullet
Caption: points we could include there we know
Caption: that it's running against a production
Caption: line we know that it's a manager that
Caption: takes action on this system
Caption: um
Caption: overall we're starting to get a better
Caption: picture of what this whole system does
Caption: but we can do better so
Caption: let's try
Caption: um so now we have a lot a lot more going
Caption: on here
Caption: um I try to run through it really
Caption: quickly for you uh of keynote is we no
Caption: longer have that black box sampling
Caption: engine right we have individual
Caption: components we have an sqs queue we have
Caption: a Lambda that takes the sample and does
Caption: something with it we have a uh we can
Caption: see that the sample goes and goes
Caption: through some sort of analyzing system
Caption: um
Caption: don't know what I'm not a canary manager
Caption: so don't ask me uh and then it gets
Caption: processed by another Lambda so we know
Caption: instead of that single black box that we
Caption: thought we had we actually have three
Caption: arguably four different components there
Caption: which is massive amounts more
Caption: information that we can convey to our
Caption: our users our stakeholders anyone who's
Caption: interested in this system brand new devs
Caption: that join the team you can go oh yeah
Caption: cool we work with you know two lambdas
Caption: and an sqsq instead of just there's this
Caption: black box and you'll eventually figure
Caption: out what it does there's tons more
Caption: information here uh we can see when it
Caption: fails we actually send a notification to
Caption: the manager it just it doesn't just
Caption: nebulously somehow get to the manager
Caption: uh who then analyzes the results and
Caption: there's some subjectivity here clearly
Caption: because otherwise we wouldn't need to
Caption: analyze the results the manager probably
Caption: wouldn't even need to be involved uh and
Caption: then you can see that based on analyzing
Caption: the results they'll restart the
Caption: production line perhaps there's other
Caption: steps they have to take before they can
Caption: do that I would assume they have to
Caption: remove the crappy product before they
Caption: restart it again I don't actually know
Caption: how cannery's work
Caption: um
Caption: but that's the basic premise right we
Caption: want to we want to convey exactly what's
Caption: happening in this system
Caption: uh clear labels for everything your
Caption: components it's not just a Lambda it's a
Caption: Lambda that takes a sample it's a Lambda
Caption: that processes sample results it's very
Caption: clear what those individual components
Caption: are doing
Caption: um
Caption: and that then helps you to convey
Caption: meaning to the rest of the people
Caption: involved in the project
Caption: so uh
Caption: this is a real world example this is
Caption: something that I used
Caption: um at a at a client this is actually
Caption: part of a smaller bit of a smaller part
Caption: of a larger architecture so this is one
Caption: component out of
Caption: four six there was multiple vpcs peering
Caption: going on
Caption: and it was all Illustrated in the
Caption: diagram we I used a little pipe symbol
Caption: to indicate that there was peering
Caption: between the various vpcs
Caption: um you know use your imagination here
Caption: use some descript some something
Caption: descriptive that's not just a box and an
Caption: arrow to get your point across in this
Caption: particular case we're talking about a
Caption: step function you can see we're using
Caption: the diamonds to indicate decision points
Caption: in the process the
Caption: gray box I'm hoping it's great it's gray
Caption: on my screen a bit in the middle there
Caption: with the map states is actually a
Caption: parallel state where it takes multiple
Caption: results and Spins up multiple lambdas
Caption: concurrently
Caption: uh not sure that's the best
Caption: representation but at least it gets the
Caption: point across that something different is
Caption: happening at that particular part of the
Caption: process which is the goal here is we
Caption: want to communicate exactly what's
Caption: happening and you can start a discussion
Caption: around that point you can go hey product
Caption: owner we're actually spinning up 20
Caption: lambdas here right this is very
Caption: different to just spinning up one Lambda
Caption: they're all processing things
Caption: concurrently and we have to take certain
Caption: actions as a result
Caption: um
Caption: down the bottom you've got external
Caption: Integrations with mulesoft that's as far
Caption: as I went with this particular diagram
Caption: you could go further the mulesoft
Caption: actually pointed it at sap whether that
Caption: adds value or not is is up to you the
Caption: one thing this doesn't include is people
Caption: uh that said this system doesn't
Caption: actually really have people in the
Caption: process it's a fully automated system so
Caption: perhaps not the best example but I
Caption: thought it would be interesting to
Caption: include include a more beefier example
Caption: of what I'm
Caption: trying to
Caption: get across here
Caption: uh cool I'm going really quick of course
Caption: so look you see really quick that's
Caption: that's basically the end of my talk so
Caption: um the key takeaways here are build
Caption: Build architecture design architecture
Caption: that includes everyone don't build these
Caption: little black boxes that only the
Caption: technical experts understand you lose so
Caption: much value your your POS they don't know
Caption: what's going on with these little black
Caption: boxes you tell them there's a Lambda
Caption: that's doing something instantly they go
Caption: oh cool I actually understand what that
Caption: is you might have to explain them how a
Caption: lambd explained to them how a Lambda
Caption: works but they're going to feel more
Caption: connected to the project they're going
Caption: to be more interested in what's
Caption: happening I've seen it time and time
Caption: again the good POS even the mediocre POS
Caption: they are way more involved in the
Caption: process if you encourage them and
Caption: include them in the whole thing they
Caption: want to be involved in this at the end
Caption: of the day that's their product right
Caption: they they want to know what's happening
Caption: with their product they are the owners
Caption: so really encourage them
Caption: to to get involved in this process and
Caption: build a process build a build a diagram
Caption: that does encourage them to do so
Caption: um
Caption: things that will help you do this single
Caption: responsibility principle right that
Caption: single black box was split into two
Caption: lambdas and a queue and they all did one
Caption: thing there was a Lambda that took a
Caption: sample
Caption: um I don't know how that works on a
Caption: cannery Factory maybe they activate a
Caption: different conveyor belt who knows but it
Caption: that's all it does it just takes a
Caption: sample when it responds to that random
Caption: sampling event and then the other Lambda
Caption: that processes the results and says it's
Caption: a pass or a fail right that's all it
Caption: does it figures out whether the results
Caption: are a pass or a fail it is very simple
Caption: architecture it's easy to understand
Caption: and everybody can understand it which is
Caption: the whole point we want people to
Caption: understand we want people to go oh can I
Caption: add this particular component what's the
Caption: impact of this particular feature or
Caption: change to the system and if they
Caption: understand the whole system they're
Caption: going to be able to have more of a
Caption: meaningful discussion with you about
Caption: that
Caption: readability and discoverability I
Caption: mentioned earlier in the talk new devs
Caption: new devs are going to understand
Caption: this a lot quicker than if I just did
Caption: that black box outside or maybe the the
Caption: um event bridge and the step function
Caption: right having all the individual
Caption: components is going to be way easier to
Caption: understand and get them up to speed and
Caption: that's what we want right we don't want
Caption: to have to spend a month teaching the
Caption: new Dev all the different parts of the
Caption: system we're going to go hey we need to
Caption: make this change to Lambda XYZ go make
Caption: that change and they can go do it
Caption: without any other involvement so
Caption: it's a really great way of onboarding
Caption: people quick and everyone getting up to
Caption: speed and everyone understanding the
Caption: system
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: and the last thing I've kind of already
Caption: touched on this opportunity to enhance
Caption: your workflow right you're not always
Caption: going to see everything just because
Caption: you're the architect doesn't mean you
Caption: always know best just because you're the
Caption: senior Dev or the tech lead just because
Caption: you're the PO doesn't mean you know the
Caption: best workflow here by having an
Caption: architecture that everybody understands
Caption: you can all work together and spot
Caption: opportunities to improve the workflow to
Caption: enhance the workflow to add new business
Caption: cases and value to that workflow
Caption: um
Caption: and that's it that's me so uh thank you
Caption: very much for coming to my tour and
Caption: question time
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: sorry thank you very much Trent so it's
Caption: not only about making inclusive software
Caption: for your customers it's about making
Caption: inclusive systems so you can basically
Caption: communicate better with the team of
Caption: people that you're working with all the
Caption: way through from exec to um your Junior
Caption: developer very good thank you now we're
Caption: going to open the floor up for some q
Caption: and A's uh has anyone got a question
Caption: just up the front
Caption: possibly a loaded question
Caption: um have you have you heard of the C4
Caption: model of architecture diagrams recently
Caption: yes yes okay
Caption: um yeah very similar I I considered
Caption: adding that to this talk and you could
Caption: uh if we look at uh say this particular
Caption: model you could you could probably apply
Caption: that here and say the um you know the
Caption: two big black boxes are one level of the
Caption: C4 and then you drill down another level
Caption: and you get a a view of the uh event
Caption: bridge and the step function and the
Caption: database and then another level when you
Caption: get the internals of the step function
Caption: and that would apply there
Caption: um but yeah uh organically came to the
Caption: same conclusions apparently I only
Caption: discovered it in the last couple of
Caption: months you've reinvented it
Caption: we discovered it ourselves about a year
Caption: ago oh nice yeah how's it working for
Caption: you that's brilliant nice excellent
Caption: yeah it's basically what you showed
Caption: there it really opens up the magic Black
Caption: Box yeah um
Caption: and uh yeah more people can understand
Caption: the system yeah great once you do that
Caption: more people can go oh hang on actually
Caption: it's a bit crap yeah yeah yeah it leads
Caption: leads to an improved system though when
Caption: they say that right so yeah it's good
Caption: cool thank you
Caption: any more questions any more questions
Caption: um have you got any advice for people
Caption: who are reviewing someone else's
Caption: architecture diagram any sort of red
Caption: flags to look out for and that sort of
Caption: thing oh yeah that's a good one no boxes
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um yeah look I uh
Caption: uh I can't think of anything off the top
Caption: I've not done a lot of reviews right I
Caption: um I tend to either pick something up
Caption: and uh try and figure out what's going
Caption: on or I'll be building the diagram
Caption: myself I guess the only thing I would
Caption: perhaps consider when doing a review is
Caption: maybe build it yourself do the diagram
Caption: yourself and see what the differences
Caption: are and make sure that you have actually
Caption: captured all the aspects of the system
Caption: might be a good way of doing it but yeah
Caption: I've never done reviews before so that's
Caption: um purely guesswork unfortunately
Caption: any more questions
Caption: um are there any particular tools that
Caption: you found sort of helpful or useful in
Caption: terms of your architecture diagrams
Caption: uh yeah look I mean there's definitely
Caption: tools out there that will generate a lot
Caption: of this stuff for you
Caption: um there was
Caption: I can't remember the name of it there
Caption: was a recent one that works really well
Caption: with arm templates and and the Azure
Caption: system I'm not sure if there's
Caption: equivalent for AWS uh these particular
Caption: diet or the um the big real world
Caption: diagram I did that in sorry I just
Caption: realized I'm not on the screen it's
Caption: there uh the big real world diagram I
Caption: did that in Vizio uh it has all the nice
Caption: icons and everything else to work with
Caption: whatever platform you're using but
Caption: drawer IO as well free open source has
Caption: same set of pitches and diagrams and
Caption: everything else and you can sync it to
Caption: Dropbox and OneDrive and all the rest
Caption: and and they're really useful tools
Caption: um
Caption: I haven't used Lucid but I do I do know
Caption: of lucid yeah yeah
Caption: um
Caption: yeah they're they're the most tools I
Caption: know about
Caption: any more questions
Caption: no okay